ah Tuesday a New York State judge
ordered a 30 year-old man to clear out
of his parents house Michael condo it
didn't pay rent or do chores basically
he's a tiny version of Congress so he
was finally sued by mom and dad after
refused to leave a self-employed
businessman
the parents have yet to see any of
Michael's secret source of income I'm
beginning to wonder what that is his
parents home was actually a sanctuary
city and he a sponge approaching 31
reaped the benefits apparently thinking
everything should be free
he almost qualifies as a commencement
speaker or at least a Vermont senator ha
yeah finally after a pile of ignored
eviction letters the judge ruled for
mom-and-pop and he had to move out but
being good parents they offered him
money to find a place to stay and to fix
his car secretly hoping he might leave
town but they also gave him sound advice
including quote organized things you
need for work and manage an apartment
and quote sell the other things that
have any significant value that's pretty
good and he added this there are jobs
available even for those with a poor
work history like you so true get one
you have to work translation get off
your butt and do something with your
life
so now evicted he worried about what's
best for him which was the advice just
given he did see his parents again after
the ruling and said it was pretty
awkward on the bright side he could
always move into a start going Duncan
Duncan you know Kimberly this guy's all
over the news it's gonna be on Martha
McCallum tonight I'm very excited I
moved in with my mom when I was 23 I
stayed for a year I thought it was
pretty good
this kid pushing it yeah I think he's
pushing it because then didn't he go
back to their house I've got a judge saw
him get up that's all got a job and then
he's like knock knock who's there me
again yeah so he's showing up to just
he's probably gonna go find poor some
unfortunate individual that'll take him
in yeah because he's got his 15 minutes
of fame and they're like taking selfies
with this guy and then when that happens
and passes over then I don't know what
he's gonna do he's probably to move back
in with his parents but I'm
what kind of self-respect does he have
look at these parents they're so sweet
look at them they didn't get a girl well
this is a good thing well he got one for
a second I guess yeah you know what the
solution is Richard is you just move in
and become somebody's Butler just become
a butler and scientific but a really bad
one
really late a lazy butler I like poor
lazy Susa or like a kato kaelin her my
only problem with this is that I think
the this word the word millennial in
this screen the screen behind because no
because listen I drew I packed up and I
went to college at 18 and I was like mom
I'm never coming back home Jake you can
always come home and I'm like no I'm
gonna get a job and I'm gonna work and
it's what all my friends did and we're
all doing great and wrong Millennials
and there's tons I'm what does it work
at this fine organization and they work
and they had their own apartment so they
don't live at home with their parents
and they pay rent what you want to hear
from him this is on a this is on an
earlier net show on a network I can't
think of the name of it starts with C do
you not want to find your own place no
why don't want to live there anymore all
right you don't want to live
no why don't you just move out of your
parents house like tomorrow but I don't
have the means to do that tomorrow okay
do you have a job no then we wish we
could please take a sip of your water
don't you want to reconcile with them no
oh my god boy he needs immediate I want
to feel best yeah do you feel bad from
you think there might be you feel bad
for everybody yeah you do but then he's
doing the TV and he's could have moved
out so it's like how bad do you think
that the lure of being on TV like you
think oh I'll go on TV I'll tell my
story but you're not a saying not
everybody can talk when they get in
front of my camera isn't seemly a little
camera shop oh ye McCallum will be able
to get you pull a little more out of
that hopefully he's got stuff for Martha
he's just so bad at being a deadbeat
if you want to be at your parents home
you can try to tell us how do you be a
good daddy have a little support
do some chores couple chores you don't
really want to go how'd you do it and
they give you another year yeah yeah
instead he's like I will do nothing
yeah yeah yeah we'll have to evict me
yes I mean that's the weird thing that
having to go to court they tried to the
victim cops that's what I would do it's
gonna be open arms could it be that Mito
six came over I'm gonna defend him and
say that because we're living longer 31
is the new 13 I agree not 13 years old
oh I beg to differ
you know you're living longer you could
stay longer that's a good point so like
what is the acceptable age so let's just
say it's 25 if you say that kids should
be on their parents health insurance
till 25 I mean I don't say that but the
law says that okay whatever points to 20
26 so 30 yeah maybe you're right with if
you do you know age I'm for close
families you know multi-generational
families all right okay did you hear
that no no but I can feel it yes I was
like getting a shock in the year